also für alle jetzt ein geheimtipp von
hausfrau zu hausfrauen natürlich für
diejenigen die ganz viele kerzen zu
hause haben und das problem haben dass
beim auspusten der kehrte schon mal der
wachs an die an die wände oder sowas
gekommen ist man nehme ein bügeleisen
und ein
haushaltsbuch also am besten ich dachte
mein ziel war auch wenn man jetzt hier
keine schleichwerbung machen darf aber
irgend sowas wenn man sagt ja und dann
legt man das schön drauf da wo der wachs
ist und bügelt dann darüber und dieses
komplette haushaltsbuch saugt den wachs
aufgrund der wärme auf und dann ist
alles wieder sauber